(audience cheering and applauding)
- H! Nice to meet you
guys, nice to meet you!
I love having the whole family here.
(audience cheering)
Oh my gosh.
So, Charli you led the way with dancing.
So have you always been a dancer?
- Yes, I've been-
- Oh my God, I didn't notice
you had freckles til just now.
Y'all are adorable, those freckles.
Sorry, keep going.
- No, I've been taking dance classes
since I was three and competing
since I was five years old
so quite some time, yeah.
- [Kelly] It's so fun though, dancing.
- Oh, yeah.
- Oh my gosh, and is it like,
I find that it like
helps me relieve stress.
- [Charli] Oh, a hundred percent.
- I will literally dance alone in my room
after I put my kids to bed.
I live a very different life from you.
And I will put on music
and literally just dance
by myself to make myself feel better.
- It's so fun.
- [Kelly] Yes, yes.
Okay, so what did you think, you know,
or I guess, what did think
it was about Charli's videos
that, you know, was so
appealing to people?
Why do you think people
started freaking out?
- I think just the fact that she
let people into a normal
teenager's life in her bedroom.
I say it all the time,
one of the first things we would say is,
"Don't you wanna make your
bed or clean up a little bit?"
And she's just like "No dad,
this is what everybody wants."
- Authentic, be authentic.
(mom laughing)
- Yeah, oh hey, that's very
authentic for a teenager.
Well Dixie, you sing and dance as well,
very talented family,
but I heard that you have a hidden talent,
so, what is that?
- My hidden talent is that I can
play the piano with my toes.
- What?
- So, growing up I spent a
lot of time, like, by myself.
Charli didn't love playing
with me when we were kids.
So, I-
- That happens when you're
the younger sister by the way.
Lisa, you hear me out there, Lisa Beth?
Yeah, I know you didn't
want to play with me.
- So, I played the violin,
and I wanted to play the
piano at the same time.
So, I just learned how to
do both at the same time.
- Wait, that is the weirdest thing I ever,
most people can't even like
play with their fingers
let alone their toes.
- Yeah.
- And by weird, I mean really cool.
- I had a lot of free time as a kid.
(Kelly laughing)
- Oh my God, I love you.
Okay, so Charli you recently
had your wisdom teeth
pulled so here you are
in the car afterward,
I love these videos.
- Is it okay?
- Yeah, it's cause they put medicine.
- Oh okay
- Yeah, yeah it'll come back.
(Charli crying out)
Where is she?
She might be working.
It's all right.
- It's okay, I love you Dixie.
- I love your ending, I love people.
It's the weirdest thing how much
I love watching people coming out of
the dentist office in these videos.
Um, do you remember any of that?
- I remember my whole face
was really, really numb.
- Oh.
- Um, it was definite,
looking back at the videos,
I think I had a really good reaction.
I did not know what to expect
at all, especially after.
- Wait, oh yeah that's
right, that's right.
We actually, we didn't leave Dixie out.
We actually have hers as well.
We want to be fair here.
Let's play Dixie's.
(Kelly chuckling)
- Mom. Literally I'm fine.
Let me eat anything.
- [Heidi] It's not happening.
- Why?
- Because.
- Please. I just want a burger.
- [Heidi] I'm not-
(Kelly laughing and crowd clapping)
- Literally, I'm fine.
Um, it's amazing, so wait,
you really wanted a burger though?
- Yeah, I hated the fact that my mom
was like, we can have
ice cream or anything.
I just wanted a burger.
I don't remember that at all.
I don't remember coming
out of the doctor's office.
They just showed me the video later.
I'm like, I don't even
like burgers that much.
(audience laughing)
I don't know what was going on.
- Or do you? Like deep
down, subconsciously.
- I mean I guess.
That wass what I was
craving. I don't know.
- It's amazing what happens sometimes
when you leave the dentist.
Um, well um, trust me I
went on a shopping spree
and had no idea what I was doing it.
It was very not safe.
Um, but Marc and Heidi, so
between Charli and Dixie
who is more dramatic?
- Charli.
- Hands, hands down.
- Oh! There was no hesitation.
(Kelly laughing)
- I wouldn't disagree.
- So, Charli your dad tried
to teach you to drive. How'd that go?
- So, in our old house before we
moved to the one we are in now.
Our driveway was really,
really complicated,
and it was really tight and of course the
first time I wanted to
really take initiative
and drive the car was in to that driveway.
- Oh.
- And last minute I freaked out,
and I forgot which one was the gas
and which one was the brake.
(audience laughing)
- Did you run into the garage?
- I didn't.
I actually ran into the
sidewalk of my neighbors yard.
- Okay, you didn't the house, oh.
- But I didn't hit anything.
- [Kelly] But it wasn't like, your lawn.
- Mm, no.
- That was a good day for that one,
at least you didn't hit the house.
- Right?
- I remember my brother, when I was little
he like did the wrong pedal and went into
the garage with the door
closed. Um, so how do
how do you think driving lessons went?
- I feel bad because I wanted it
to be that experience
that dads and kids have
when you take your daughter
out and I did a dad
move and got and I just grabbed the wheel
and went like that and I
got her really nervous so.
- Um, I don't think I'm ever
gonna do that with my kids.
I will let somebody else do that.
It would drive me nuts.
I think yeah, I know this.
I'm not gonna do that to my children.
Um, but putting videos online and being
as popular as you are, um, and as popular
as your videos are.
Can sometimes get blow back.
I've been in the public eye for 20 years.
You can get some nasty people out there.
I advise you to never read it.
Don't read the good or the bad.
- Yeah.
- Because if you read the good, your ego
explodes and you become
just an unlikable human.
And then if you read
the bad, then you wanna
crawl in a hole and die
cause people are so mean.
- Yeah.
- So, it's really not a
good, it's not a way to win,
but what is your experience from it?
Cause y'all are of an
age where social media
is just so different than it was for us.
We didn't have this kind of pressure.
How do you handle it?
- I feel like we're doing a lot better
of a job now at, not really
reading it because obviously
you want to read all the great stuff
but with that comes the negative.
So it's just easier to kind
of not look at it and then
engage with only the positive.
I used to engage with a
lot of the negative and
it would draw people's attention to it
and now I just appreciate the people that
appreciate me and I think that's
the best way to handle it.
(audience clapping)
- Yeah, absolutely!
And just people can be mean.
People can be mean, they
just wanna say mean things
cause their so unhappy and it's like worry
about yourselves, stay in your lane,
get on your own front porch.
Um, but I don't know I
always say, don't look at it.
I still say don't look at it.
(crowd laughing)
But anyway, but why,
why did you want to do
the docuseries, like why were
y'all interested in this?
- I think for the reason that when
the kids got on social media
everybody had a preconceived
notion of who we are and
we're like well if we're
going to be this popular and
they're putting ourselves
out there we might as well
let people into our lives
and then if they don't like
us, then they don't like who
us we really are not just
a 15 second video of us.
- Absolutely.
Um, so we've seen you guys dance a ton.
I love dancing.
Um, we should see what your parents
can do um is what I'm saying.
(audience cheering)
- I love that.
- We have, we have seen your moves.
But we have not seen
where they have come from.
(Heidi laughing)
Okay, well why don't y'all get up.
Let's see y'all's moves, let's see it.
Come on, come on
- Right up here?
- You can do it! You can do it!
(audience cheering)
I'm gonna get up and dance.
(upbeat music starts playing)
(clapping and Kelly cheering)
Oh my God, your parents are so cute.
They are so cute!